now last night we heard from two gold
star fathers they lost their hero marine
sons in last week's terror attack at
karzai international airport in kabul
the attack caused by joe biden's
self-inflicted reckless afghan exit
disaster all preventable all of this
human suffering all of this violence the
needless loss of life it's all caused by
biden now we know he knew even as he
tries to blame everybody else
except himself here with reaction fox
news contributor joey jones and nevada
senate candidate sam brown who both
served and were wounded in afghanistan
along with gold star wife jenny taylor
her husband army major brent taylor
killed in afghanistan in 2018. joey let
me start with you
in 2010 ied related incident resulted in
the loss of both your legs above the
knee severe damage to your right forearm
both wrists how do you feel today
well first sean just let me say that
whatever injuries i sustained are
nothing compared to the to the pain that
the gold star family has gone through
i've seen it firsthand i haven't
experienced it thank god and my heart
goes out to all of them the dozens that
i know and the 13 that were just created
and and everyone uh that has lost a hero
overseas
but what bothered me so much is you know
there's all these excuses that come up
from joe biden checking his watch maybe
he was looking at a rosary that was his
son maybe this maybe that you shouldn't
have to maybe if you're the family of
someone who died just days ago in an
operation that much of the country
thinks
wasn't on the up and up didn't the intel
wasn't correct or the president made bad
decisions maybe as the president united
states you need to just be there and be
in that moment and be there for them and
if it means that you're the verbal
punching bag today that's okay i mean i
mean heck man you just went through
something that's that's nobody should go
through and you're gonna say things and
have emotions that may be different a
week from now and we all understand that
so i don't want to use the words of gold
star families as some political punching
bag but i just was i hadn't had the
wherewithal
as the president united states to be
there be in the moment and show them
that respect and if they say he didn't
i'll take the word for it and just say
that we all deserve better
let me ask you sam brown you graduated
from west point you got a great
distinction you became an airborne
ranger september 08 you were struck by
an ied it severely wounded you a
three-year journey of rehabilitation and
recovery
um your thoughts today
do you have any regrets about serving
the way this now has ended
you know sean i've got a message for the
american people and this is not just me
this is after talking to many other
veterans who served there
some my own family members i'm i'm the
one of three in my direct family who
have served in afghanistan and there's
there's two themes that's coming out
from this
one is most of us don't regret what we
did there because at the end of the day
we are confident in the help and the
assistance and the security that we
provided for the afghans that we had
care over at that time and for whatever
period of time that they had some some
shelter and security from the taliban or
other threats that was worth something
and we're we we feel good about that but
what we don't appreciate and what joe
biden has almost single-handedly along
with the the top brass leadership out of
dod has done has caused many of us
to feel that we have been lied to over
the years about our commitment to the
afghan people into the mission there and
here's here's the really sad thing and
here's what america needs to know
is and sean i know you know this
many of those who serve in uniform come
from multi-generational families
here's here's the second thing that
people are telling me today
we're done
joe biden has lost the trust and faith
of those families
many families who have served for
generations that we would raise our
right hand and be
available at the direction of the
commander-in-chief
and do what our country asked us to do
and people are saying we're done my
children my grandchildren will not be a
tool of elected and unelected officials
their priorities their foreign policy
objectives we will not be tools for that
and that's a sad sad indictment of where
we're at in america when you have folks
that are saying that and so what i'm
what i'm telling folks is that we need
to make sure that we push back against
these elected officials and that we
demand accountability from our top brass
out of dod
people
can hear my full statement on joe biden
asking for his resignation at my website
captainsandbrown.com
and join me on this mission of bringing
back some honor and integrity to our
armed services
jenny taylor your gold star wife
you have seven children
your husband was killed november 3rd
2018
in afghanistan he served with the utah
national guard
you you said for those that say was it
worth it you said i don't think that for
a second that it was a waste but you
also said that you've talked to many
other
gold star families
and it feels like every one of us is
reliving this
seven children will never see their dad
i i
i can't imagine
you know sean i was listening to
everything you're saying so far and
we're talking about ninety percent of
the people getting evacuated or we
should go for a hundred percent well
i've got one statistic for you a hundred
percent of gold star kids don't get to
get raised by that parent that's missing
a hundred percent of gold star moms will
never get to hug their son or daughter
again a hundred percent of gold star
spouses like me will spend the rest of
our lives without our sweetheart i will
tell you what i will not wonder i will
never wonder if my husband died in vain
or why he served or if it was worth it i
will never let myself get to the point
where i think that was a waste or never
should have been should have happened
do i like the way things have happened
lately of course not none of us approve
of the current situation but i will
never question why my husband served why
the other 2500 have died in this war and
the thousands that have died for the
other wars the other causes throughout
america's history we die because of what
we believe in we believe in these
principles we believe in hope we believe
in spreading humanity and opportunity
around the world my husband didn't just
die to protect me and our seven little
babies he died because he believed the
afghan people also deserved a chance
they deserved hope and opportunity
education and freedom and i'll tell you
something that i hope the american
people realize i hope this really sinks
in
men like my husband and the 13 who were
killed last week and the thousands that
have died in this 20-year war on
terrorism they died trying to make a
difference they died trying to make it
better they died trying to make it work
and the question i have for all of us
now is are we willing to live with that
same dedication are we willing to live
in a way that makes it worth it to them
to honor the lives that they have given
because again a hundred percent of gold
star families have lost at least 90
percent of that
chance they've lost all of that
opportunity to be with that loved one
again for the rest of their mortal lives
that's a really heavy statistic
jenny sam and joey i i
there aren't enough words you guys have
been through so much
very hard for people to
relate to but i can tell you this
i know i speak for myself and i know i
speak for this audience i want to thank
each and every one of you for all of
your service and sad sacrifice and pain
that you've all been through
i just want to say thank you
you are what you are the people that
make america great you are the great
americans
that we love and admire
we never leave americans behind thank
you for sharing your stories with the
audience god bless you all i appreciate
our prayers all of you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else